bien mâcher amis je vous propose de de
commencer comme d'habitude avec un petit
quart d'heure par rapport à l'horaire
deux amis continuent à arriver
nous allons parler ce matin
d'environnement de mer et d'énergie vous
savez qu'on a abordé beaucoup de sujets
depuis depuis maintenant quelques mois
mais nous sommes en phase d'accélération
pour celles et ceux qui suivent nos
débats depuis le début vous avez pu vous
avez pu assister à des des prises de
positions et des propositions sur des
sujets aussi différents que
l'immigration que la sécurité que le
code du travail que la réforme
nécessaire de la fonction publique où
évidemment les questions d'économie et
les questions d'emploi
alors nous nous parlons ce matin
notamment d'énergie et d'environnement
c'est absolument un sujet considérables
et c'est un sujet majeur
la semaine prochaine nous aborderons les
questions de défense nationale c'est
aussi un sujet considérable et majeur au
fond d'eux le sont tous
on aura beaucoup de travail si on
revient au pouvoir d'ici l'année
prochaine
et puis on appellera la nécessaire
refondation et cette fois ci je crois
qu'elle est possible compte tenu du
contexte politique européen la
nécessaire refondation de l'europe et
des institutions européennes et puis à
la fin du mois de mai ou début juin
nous parlerons de protection sociale et
de santé plus on poursuivra le grand
rendez vous c'est le 2 juillet le 2
juillet ce sera un conseil national qui
votera sur le projet dans son ensemble
donc à partir des briques que nous
élaborons semaine après semaine
mais aussi bien sûr par rapport à une
vision plus générale que l'ensemble de
ces briques alors ce matin nous parlons
d'environnement de mer et des énergies
l'idée c'est que l'environnement et ne
doit pas être totalement capter
monopolisée par la gauche la droite a
évidemment une vision de l'environnement
il ya une vision
des républicains il ya une vision de
droite et du centre des problématiques
d'environnement et maud fontenoy délégué
général à l'environnement évidemment
pendant toute la matinée va évoquer et
montrer en quoi consiste cette vision
sur tous les thèmes que nous allons
traiter et nous voulons affirmer cette
vision il est possible qu'il y ait du
progrès du progrès il est possible que
la croissance il est possible évidemment
qui la protection de l'environnement il
suffit pas de le dire
tout le monde le dit il faut évidemment
pouvoir le montrer et pouvoir le faire
chaque jour et en même temps évidemment
à moyen et long terme n'ya pas
d'environnement s'il n'y a pas de
raisonnement à la lenteur
l'environnement c'est aussi une question
de souveraineté
il n'y a pas que la finance il n'y a pas
que la défense nationale c'est une
question de souveraineté quand on pense
à l'énergie c'est une question de
souveraineté nationale et souveraineté
européenne
notre puissance maritime c'est une
question de souveraineté sont donc des
facteurs absolument essentiel pour
l'indépendance de notre pays et puis
l'environnement c'est aussi la vie on
parlera de ville comment et comment
faire évoluer nos villes on parlera de
paysages on parlera évidemment des ronds
pas le radeau bien entendu on parlera
d'électricité on parlera aussi de
démographie la démographie comme vous le
savez est galopant sur notre planète et
le lien entre l'environnement la
protection de notre planète terre et la
démographie sont indissociables et puis
on parlera aussi de nouvelles formes
d'économie je pense à l'économie
circulaire par exemple il faut aussi
mettre fin à un certain nombre de
vieilles lunes et puis aussi une
présentation souvent hypocrite des
choses je prends deux exemples qui
seront dans le débat le principe de
précaution on en a beaucoup parlé depuis
maintenant deux ans j'ai déposé une
proposition de loi au titre des
républicains à l'assemblée nationale qui
a été examiné il ya maintenant à peu
près deux ans évidemment à l'apave
beaucoup de d'avenir cette proposition
de loi elle s'est fracassé sur le mur du
vote socialiste et du vote des verts nos
amis sénateurs ont fait la même
chose nous devons remplacer ce principe
de précaution qui est en charge de
l'environnement qui est dans la
constitution de la vème république c'est
nous qui l'avons fait donc on peut être
amené à dire quelques dizaines d'années
après qu' il faut faire évoluer les
choses
il faut remplacer ce principe de
précaution parce qu'en france on
supprime jamais complètement
on remplace souvent donc il faut
remplacer ce principe de précaution et
nous en nous en parlerons et puis au
delà du principe de précaution est aussi
une grande hypocrisie qui est celle de
la loi de transition énergétique avec
notamment son fameux 50 % à 2025 on
considère que c'est pas possible c'est
d'ailleurs pas souhaitable c'est ni
souhaitable ni possible et ce sera
évidemment au coeur des débats de tout à
l'heure ces changements tous ces
changements ils sont bien sûr
fondamentaux et pour revenir en un mot
sur l'énergie qui fera l'objet de la
dernière table ronde
on a évoqué le président de la
république un nicolas sarkozy a évoqué
le sujet du nucléaire de façon assez
clair c'est net comme il se faire sur
dans l'est dans les journaux ces
derniers jours la france est l'un des
pays les moins carboné du monde grâce à
nos centrales nucléaires grâce aussi à
notre énergie hydro électrique
nos centrales c'est donc un bien
fondamental une richesse fondamentale un
capital un patrimoine national
considérable nous parler de leur durée
de vie de l'extension de leur durée de
vie les américains ont moins de pudeur
que que nous parler de la fermeture ou
de la non fermeture
et pour ce qui nous concerne évidemment
de la non fermeture de fessenheim
parlait dink l'époque c'est à dire la
capacité pour nos ingénieurs de
conserver une filière nucléaire
ah bon niveau est absolument essentiel
parler de l'avenir d'edf dans ce
contexte n'est pas non plus
négligeable il faut donc défendre cette
filière défendre ses technologies et
enfin aussi évoqué puisque note une
énergie peu carbonée que l'énergie doit
être de moins en moins carboné parler du
prix du carbone et de cette fameuse taxe
carbone qui a fait couler beaucoup
d'encre pas que de lancre d'ailleurs
c'est dernières années et on devra là
dessus aussi prendre position ce que
nous ferons au cours de cette matinée
alors dans cette matinée eh bien il ya
trois tables rondes la première table
ronde va commencer immédiatement
elle est animée par yannick moreau qui
est député de la vendée qui connaît bien
les problématiques de demers et de
puissance maritime dont qui a préparé
cette table ronde avec l'ensemble des
des experts et des élus qui nous entoure
donc une grande table ronde sur la
france puissance maritime redevenir une
grande puissance maritime
on pense aussi à la pêche on pense aussi
à nos ports évidemment je salue daniel
fasquelle éminemment également concernés
et puis il ya deux tables rondes qui
seront qui suivent qui sont toutes les
deux présidées par maud fontenoy mode
animera la première table ronde sur les
politiques d'environnement
d'une manière plus large et dix ans que
ces politiques d'environnement et
traduisent aussi une vision du monde
c'est pas une politique comme ça qu'on
plaques et puis qu'on change la semaine
suivante
c'est une vision du monde et on essaiera
de montrer en quoi consiste cette vision
du monde beaucoup d'intervenants dans
cette table ronde est la dernière table
ronde éminemment importante sur notre
souveraineté énergétique on évoquera
évidemment df l'énergie et c'est tout ce
que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure et comme
d'habitude les choses se termineront par
un discours du président sarkozy qui
résumera et qui fera les propositions
qui seront soumises après au vote des
militants
je vous souhaite une très bonne matinée